let's talk about the national debates
there is a very reasonable possibility
that Donald Trump will not debate
Hillary Clinton period this election
there are three debates scheduled this
fall one in Hempstead New York one in
st. Louis Missouri and one in Las Vegas
there's also a vice presidential debate
scheduled here is the format for each of
these three debates first of all we have
that first debate at Hofstra University
six times segments of 15 minutes each on
major topics to be selected by the
moderator and announced at least one
week before the second presidential
debate at Washington University in st.
Louis that one will have a town meeting
format and then the third presidential
debate at the University of Nevada Las
Las Vegas it will be an identical format
to the first presidential debate this is
from the Commission on Presidential
Debates Donald Trump is already laying
the groundwork for saying he wants to
debate but the entire thing needs to be
up to his standards here is a quote from
a phone call that Donald Trump did with
Time magazine where he said about the
debates I will absolutely do three
debates I want to debate very badly but
I have to see the conditions some of
those conditions apparently who the
moderators are Trump going on to say
during this time magazine phone
interview and we will put that up for
you I'll have to see who the moderators
are yeah I would say that certain
moderators would be unacceptable
absolutely I did very well in the
debates on the primaries according to
the polls I won all of them so I look
forward to the debates but yeah I want
to have fair moderators I will demand
fair moderators Trump likes to talk
about how he negotiated the primary
debates right the primary debates were
run by commercial television channels
working together with the Republican
National Committee these national
debates are run by the Commission on
presidential debates they are not run by
TV networks this is a nonprofit
organization the Commission that was
created after the 84 election if he's
not going to release his taxes Louis
imagine if he doesn't debate
it's it would probably help him you then
didn't debate well yeah he can every
time he talks he loses support well I
think if you believe that the the actual
act of debating will hurt him then maybe
net net not debating would be a positive
I believe if he announces initially he's
not going to debate that is absolutely
going to hurt hurt him the question is
will it end up hurting him less than
actually debating if you believe that
the debates themselves would be a
disaster it's sort of hard to know we
will never know
he either will debate or he won't and
thus we will only be able to measure the
repercussions over the decision he
actually makes yeah and I mean if he
debates the question is will his general
strategy of just attacking whoever is on
stage next to him legitimately or just
slinging insults at them will that
actually help him yeah a lot of
questions around these debates and Trump
at least opening the door to not
debating at all I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between eleven hundred and
sixteen hundred pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering twenty five dollars a
free driving credit if you sign up at
join Zipcar comm slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
Zipcar comm slash david